fast forward more than a sanctuary india
in the 1970s at the peak of the world
health organization's global smallpox
eradication campaign
smallpox has been eradicated in africa
south asia is one of the last outposts
of the virus
and the who has shifted from a strategy
of universal vaccination to what is
known as surveillance
containment a zealous and committed
cardras of
indian doctors and health workers and
foreign epidemiologists are going from
village to village
to locate cases of smallpox and
vaccinate
all contacts in a ring to stop
transmission of the virus
now if you read the report of this
campaign a somewhat dry document called
the management of smallpox in india
it's dedicated to a spiritual leader
neem karoli baba by all accounts an
extraordinary mystic who was also the
guru of ramdas timothy leary krishna das
but how it was that this report penned
by a doctor from san francisco
dr larry brilliant came to be dedicated
to neem karoli baba
i'll let you figure that out and the
hint is that you might want to dig into
the archives of the long now foundation
seminars
but if you read this report and other
reports you can see the importance
of smallpox zero teams as they were
called
convincing local notables religious
leaders to endorse the vaccination
and how important this was for them to
convince people
to roll up their sleeve further even
though there was a substantial
foreign and western presence and role in
the campaign
under the advice of culturally sensitive
epidemiologists like
dr brilliant they were very aware of the
cultural morals and rituals
associated with sitala indeed the
smallpox zero teams
realized that the families of smallpox
patients
might evade them but they would never
hide from the goddess
so they camped at sitla manders to
detect cases
and convince family members to be
vaccinated
and they often set up vaccination
stations at sithala temples
in doing so they actively presented
themselves as working with
indeed even devotees of the goddess
sithila
rather than working against her